[موسيقى]
عيد الاضحى مره اخرى يطرق ابواب غزه
المحاصمه
يستقبله محمد بكل ما يغمر وجدانه من مشاعر
مع انه سيدفع ثمن الاضحيه بالتقسيط
اضطرينا انه احنا
بشكل تقسيط لانه ما في في التزامات علينا
ماليه وفي مصروفات اخرى للبيت فاحنا هذه
الشعيره من شعائر دينيه واقامه سنه فاحنا
كل سنه الحمد لله بنضحي ومتعودين عليها بس
السنه هذه اضطرينا انه ناخذ بالتقسيط لانه
النظر للوضع الاقتصادي
الاضاحي متوفره ولد الناس فرصه للدفع
بالتقسيط لكن اسعارها مرتفعه لا طاقه
لعامه الناس بها التجار
علينا حق الاعلاف حق العجول حق حق الاغنام
الامر لا يختلف كثيرا فيما يتعلق باسواق
الملابس ومستلزمات العيد
فاقتصاد قطاع غزه في ركود بين حصار
اسرائيلي مستمر وعدم انتظام في صرف رواتب
الموظفين واموال الشؤون الاجتماعيه يعني
انا تقريبا في كل عيد باضحي لكن عيد هذا
للاسف الشديد انا مش قادر اضحي اول حاجه
اللي بسبب ارتفاع اسعار الاضاح اثنين يعني
انا بالنهايه باكثر من مناسبه ما عنديش
امكانيه ان انا يعني عيد الفطر اشتريت
للاولاد وعندي انا عندي اسره ممتده وعندي
عيد الاضحى بدي اشتري وفي عندي مدارس
قادمه رواتب احنا بناخذ 80% يعني وضع
اقتصادي بصراحه صعب يخلينا يعني نكون
حذرين في صرف كل شيكل يلا يلا جيب اكل
عيشه انا بنزل انا بنزل اتسلى بنزل اتسلى
يعني من دون صاحب بيت من وين يعبي غاز من
وين
واللي عنده اطفال روضه من وين في عالم
مغطيه بقش تعكس الحركه الشرائيه في هذه
الاسواق احوال سكان القطع الذين
يحرم كثير منهم من ذبح الاضاحي او شراء
ملابس جديده الا انهم يحرسون رغم كل ذلك
على استقبال عيد الاضحى وتقاسم الفرح
بينهم دون حدود هشام زقوط الجزيره غزه
فلسطين